oh hey there buddy welcome multiple
players yeah I'm your host Chris waters
joining me for some hammer time
it's Mary Kish and Tom McShea
and max hull Borges in game who are you
playing us and what are yours put your
moves I got this really nice green stick
aha
what's your what's your character's name
Jackie I am Raul the Paladin ya are
silver because my father was killed by
silver and I can run which is super
helpful if I need to run very short
distances Raul the coward who runs away
from battle got these green stink bombs
like this here take that
BAM what is that Oh terrible I like to
call him Pedro I'm playing as the red
Margaret the mage over here oh there's
some apples take those yum yum yum you
it actually enabled Oh Georgie no yeah
be your iron halfway yeah Oh Jackie it's
all the next time I've been poisoned
I've been poisoned easily you guys are
jerks
Johnny nice range Jackie don't worry
yeah I just run away
Margarette son flip set them on fire get
run towards that Apple thank god these
bats have white eyes or I'd never see
them in this day that would be really
nasty okay look Jackie saves the day
this - is only oh wow Jackie got
poisoned again I don't like anything so
Tom I didn't listen to you I got
poisoned together no what did I say
about getting poisoned not to do it
yes seedy character don't stop
strange planks yeah we need to go back
now nobody say it in the right boys
that's all hey strange planks around the
castle
no that's no comma after
he was not addressing us as strange
links I do not follow your situation
Rollo you set these things on fire Paul
I miss Paul is your battle cry oh give
under you the single-season rich back
you guys let's do it yes we just find
the song I found a strange point found a
strange path what's that alright that
was it did you play honest Ron's plug
throgs Bob this is one of the status
ailments that playing video games of
flicks Tom with is just like his reading
ability plummets balloon I could found
this to the strong POC my friend - uh-oh
Norman B didn't you say you called mana
mana mana I did yes that's weird eek rid
of mana I don't know if I heard of mana
mana mana what do you guys think
mana alright just told you apples
oh well I died we're three Smartline uh
Jackie Claire - oh look at that oh my
god mana Oh
dictionary.com is on Team Chris you know
why I put myself in here everybody saved
me
Raul when was the last time you killed
him use your special skill and run away
but gets that thing when we played
briefly oh look at who's looking who's
all gung-ho now that the enemies are all
cleared out what's this oh man you said
Oh Margaret took one in the thigh watch
what I can do mm-hmm
he thinks he's so hot oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
twice dammit dishes all right Helen are
going huh no oh no you dodged it ago me
I'm sorry why is it you told me I got a
lot of birds oh I feel like there's only
me what are these kidneys can we shoot
some bad guys hey you sword people yeah
we stop reading books Tom could you
please read this and
cool boy yeah can you go back actually
the Tom can you read them so they know
back and we talked me over that first
time you made fun of my shred and I want
to do it again Punk you guys wanna do it
again
it was so long ago I'm gonna hang out
hang back your life's a lie below means
trouble
what am I in a new [ __ ] - there's go
in there and very shaman rave look see
now we can all we can all tag-team
apples I get one okay so I'm gonna hold
down okay but more than one all right
this is this is a recipe for its
disaster someone is gonna die I really
can't do a literally get off that one
that was not helpful
so I don't step on any of them I'm gonna
water it okay good work good work right
all right let me go through oh wait I
can't stop odd yeah stop it okay all
right I got an up go get go get all the
coins over there it's imagine them
special barrels yeah this is your time
to shine yeah come over
what jeez sorry about all right we gonna
wake it don't run over any bus like that
why I have well I know what was in the
chest
this is Raul's time to shine catching up
and then leaving all right all mine you
all max you just oh wow that was brutal
that was a rout I'll be like that was
blatant murder would not all right
there's another step harder all right
well I'm knocking nobody move max go
ahead Mary ha ha ha what's our sponsor
vengeance oh yeah
Oh blood has been paid for in blood
hello cooperative indeed she's here can
we get some I'm not gonna lose any of
you it's so free just don't walk on
though dude I Kris no I'm just waiting
for all I was hoping no you were
can you can you guys just go step on
some of those buttons what a little on
the right
oh now you want us to step on the button
yes I do you make up your mind it's very
clear when you should step on buttons
and when you should just not step on
anybody's all right we have to go around
hi there's only one get off of all
button both of you guys jaw you son of a
[ __ ] oh I should get off of all money
really and then you step directly on one
we have one life oh right
this is a debacle oh my lord this is
where I shine with one life there you go
step on no buttons do not theory oh go
away
good god wait just wait so I get to the
edge okay brick Christmas oh my goodness
yeah Wow there's no reason to yell Chris
yeah there's no reason to step on a
button when someone says step on no
buttons oh yeah
you